quick reminder at the top here the
Western conservative summit is June 8th
and June 9th
so that's Friday and Saturday I'm gonna
be speaking on Friday morning I hope you
can come out it's in Denver I guess I
should probably let you know that it's
in Denver and and the theme this year is
it's a good theme it's fortifying
freedom which is not only catchy with
the alliteration but it's also just a
really a very meaty kind of subject and
I have a few things to say about freedom
that I hope will be useful to now I want
to talk about spiritual stuff today I
tell you that by way is disclaimer at
the top
this particular show will be rated R for
religious just so you know I know that
that kind of content is disturbing and
distasteful to some people so just fair
warning now I received an email from
somebody who who brings up an
interesting subject and I thought it'd
be worth discussing with you the subject
is guilt
I will I'll summarize the email for you
he says he's a Christian he's always
been a Christian though recently he
finds that he's experiencing a lot of
guilt for past sins for things in his
past and very intense guilt sometimes
and he's not sure what he should do with
these feelings or if he should even be
feeling them isn't the Christian life
supposed to be guilt-free that's what a
lot of people seem to think he says that
the church he attends is not much help
because it's a it's a church that tends
to treat guilts as an objectively bad
thing you know but you should just let
go of you should forget move on not
worry about it
his church seems to preach he didn't use
this term but he seems to preach kind of
a self acceptance gospel where guilt is
nothing but an obstacle to be overcome
he wants to know if I have a better
answer to the question of guilt I don't
know if I do I hope that I do I'll give
it a try so
few things on the subject of guilt first
it's a good sign
if you have it
if you have guilt that's it that's a
good sign
it doesn't mean that you're meant to
stew in it or drown in it
your whole life but it is a good sign
it's a sign of spiritual alertness
it's a sign of love
guilt is a is a is a sign of love
now many Christians I think today
it would it would seem that many
Christians today feel very little guilt
and so that means the Christians who do
feel guilt they end they end up feeling
even more alone and more lost and
confused because their fellow Christians
can't seem to relate to them
because there are some who can live in
sin can be dishonest gossipy
materialistic selfish lustful so on and
so forth and yet feel almost no guilt
for it
and the thing is they'll say that they
lack this guilt because they have faith
in God and so what they claim is that
their lack of guilt is a sign a symptom
of their of their faith and of their
confidence in God's forgiveness but
that's not really the case
simply not the case
their lack of guilt is due to their lack
of love for God
a Christian who has never experienced
serious deep guilt either has never
sinned
not in that category I don't know about
you or the other explanation is they
don't love God and they don't really
care about their faith those are really
the only two explanations for a
Christian who has really just never
experienced this guilt I've used this
analogy before but if you cheat on your
wife and you feel no guilt for it
and maybe you apologize but you're like
yeah my bad about it sorry about the
whole tree cheating thing anyway what's
for dinner if you have a callous
disregard for your wife and for your
valves you can't claim that this is
somehow a sign of your confidence in
those vows you can't claim it oh yeah
well I know I don't feel guilty because
I know my wife loves me and she wouldn't
want me to feel guilty so that's why I
don't feel guilty no that's if you
approach it that way if you feel no
guilt for betraying your wife in such a
terrible evil way it's because you don't
love your wife
and you don't care about your vows
and therefore you're very far away from
the place that you need to be in order
for reconcile in order for true
reconciliation to happen in order for
the marriage to be healed you're very
far away from them even if your wife is
a wonderful loving person and is ready
to forgive it has a forgiving heart the
marriage cannot be saved while you still
have that attitude
there are many Christians who have never
struggled deeply with guilt never feel
the weight of it don't understand what
you mean when you talk about it and so
that means they can't repent because the
repentance would not be sincere and
without love for God and without
repentance then their souls are in a
very dangerous State
and to even call them Christian at all
is well it's it's a bit of a stretch
let's just say
you have guilt then your guilt the skill
that you feel it means at the very least
that you're aware of your sins that
you're alert spiritually that you love
God you love God enough to feel
distraught by your betrayal of them
remember when you were a kid and how it
always felt so much worse wait what oh
you know if you got in trouble it always
felt least for me I know it always felt
so much worse if your parents said I'm
disappointed you know they don't yeah oh
they don't scream they just tell you
they're disappointed that always felt
worse especially if they really appear
to be disappointed
like I don't know if you ever a kid and
you did some specially when you get a
little bit older and you did something
really bad and you and you hurt your
pain they look that you it's clear that
you hurt them
and they're almost too hurt to even be
angry
um
that data always that that's always the
worst right that's always so much worse
because you can tell that their their
disappointment in you and in what you
did is is is rooted in their love for
you
and this gives rise to guilt on your
part that's rooted in your love for them
so that's the one thing we should
remember that guilt itself is is a good
sign
second we should remember that guilt
itself is not the problem
you know it's uncomfortable it's painful
depending on the situation depending on
the guilt it can even feel crushing
sometimes but the guilt is your the
guilt is your souls response to sin
so sin is the problem guilt is not the
problem it's not we shouldn't talk about
getting rid of guilt
sin is the problem guilt true guilt you
know what what I think we could call
healthy guilt is the Holy Spirit working
within you calling you to repentance and
reconciliation I think the problem in
our society today and in the church
especially is that we kind of go to war
against guilt but not against sin we
treat guilt as the problem itself as if
a healthy Christian ought to feel no
guilt whatsoever no matter what he does
but this is a sign of a dead Christian
of a non Christian of a soul that's on
the precipice of hell
that's not the sign of a healthy
Christian the church should battle
against sin and teach us how to respond
to guilt what to do with it so that we
can be free from the burden of the sin
that sparked the guilt not free from
guilty the the the objective is to be
free from sin not free from guilt
to be free from guilt because you're
free of sin
I think guilt without a without a
correct understanding of sin guilt
without an understanding of divine
justice can lead us to despair
and I think that's one of the reasons
why we see so much despair in our
secular society so many people that are
just even if everything else around them
even if their whole life seems like it's
a wonderful life in so many ways is
still so many people are in despair and
one of the reasons for them not saying
the only reason but one of the reasons I
think in so many cases is is this kind
of guilt that they can't they don't know
what to do with it
they just have it
it brings to mind one of my favorite
scenes in my favorite show of all time
Breaking Bad
and in this scene so brilliant scene
Jesse Pinkman one of the primary
characters in the show he's a drug
dealer also a drug addict and he's at
this kind of drugs it's kind of like a
Narcotics Anonymous I guess meeting and
they're all sitting around in a circle
on folding chairs and the leader of the
group is preaching self acceptance he's
telling everyone just let go of your
guilt let go of your past let go the
shame accept yourself for who you are
forget about your past actions forget
about past evils and just move on well
Jesse it just so happens at this point
in the show has just murdered an
innocent man and he killed him because
he thought he had to he rationalized it
that way but now the guilt of that
action and of his life of crime in
general that guilt is just eating him
alive
and he hears all this stuff about
self-acceptance but it's just garbage to
him it rings so Hollow
it's just it's not there's there
something deeper that he needs and
self-acceptance and moving on that
doesn't it doesn't that's not gonna do
it for so he launches into this
brilliant monologue I think one of the
most morally insightful monologues in
the history of television where he's
crying out and he's saying you know that
that that he should be punished for what
he's done he should be judged he doesn't
want to accept himself
he doesn't want to accept his sin he
wants there to be some kind of
consequence because what's the point of
life if you can just do whatever you
want and face no judgement at all
kind of a theme right out of Dostoevsky
which is probably why I liked it so much
but the point is that letting go of
guilt which is what you know he was
being told in this support group just
just let go let go
that's not good enough it's not a good
enough answer for those who are morally
aware enough to actually experience true
guilt
it's not good enough there has to be
repentance there has to be
accountability there has to be justice
even those who are not Christian yet who
have well-formed consciences
still kind of innately recognized
Christians who do not have well-formed
consciences do not recognize this
so I think what the church should be
saying is it here's what I think the
church should be saying about guilt the
church should be saying you feel guilt
because you've sinned
are detestable and you are right to feel
the way you do about them you've
betrayed your father who loves you and
if you love him you should hate that
fact and you should hate your sin and
you should feel pain because of it
now take all of that before him and
repent
and resolve to never do it again
and you've got to have that resolution
also if you don't have the resolution
even if you fail to perfectly carry it
out if you don't make that resolution
and mean it then it's not repentance
third thing
then the question is maybe the most
difficult question is well what do we do
about repentance sins that still bring
guilt
what if you've really reformed your life
you've repented you resolve to live
differently and you're really carrying
that out though imperfectly you really
have changed through God's grace and yet
still you have guilt
for a past that you can't do anything
about anymore
maybe you've done terrible things you
can't do anything about it it's in it's
it's you wish it never happened but it
did
and you still feel guilt up for it even
though you've repented and you've thrown
yourself on the mercy of God what do you
do about that and what does that come
from
now I think
speaking above my paygrade here because
this is a very deep question but
as I thought about I think there could
be a couple of different explanations
for that kind of guilt
different explanations so each person
has to discern prayerfully which
explanation applies to their case
personally but I think that persistent
guilt for repented sins
could be the result of Satan tormenting
scripture tells us that Satan is our
accuser and he's quite relentless in his
accusations and of course he doesn't
care if you've repented he'd prefer if
you didn't but that's not gonna make him
stop so he might accuse you of repented
sins to discourage you from repenting in
the future because he might he wants you
to feel like repentance is kind of
fruitless
but mostly I think he just likes to see
you suffer he enjoys it and he wants you
to find faith and religion burdensome
and tiring and painful
and he wants you to see it as a source
of self-loathing so that you abandoned
and also I think I think Satan is is is
interested in punishing you for
repenting
takes that personal he doesn't like it
and so he's he's gonna try to speak to
you in the back your mind and say oh
yeah well remember what you did remember
remember this remember this thing you
did you disgusting person
but here again even this guilt which is
um which is really more of a false guilt
because it comes not from the Holy
Spirit but from the evil spirit but even
this guilt is a sign that you know
you're kind of on to something that
you're a threat to Satan that he knows
that you're almost lost to him but
you're on the right path and he doesn't
like that so he throws this against you
this is a desperate that this is when
Satan gets a really desperate this is
his most desperate move it's when he
starts doing this he's trying to just
scare you
he doesn't bother keep mine he doesn't
bother tormenting the shallowest kinds
of people with guilt because their
consciences are too dead anyway and they
have no love for God so he's got nothing
to work with and he doesn't need to
anyway he's he's perfectly fine you know
he's perfectly fine with those kinds of
people just let them be comfortable and
if they never feel any guilt then that's
great as far as he's concerned
but um
but if you're struggling deeply with
guilt
then that means that he has raw material
to work with so like look at it this way
if you're kind of a prodigal son figure
you live deeply in sin now you've come
to God and you've come sincerely and
you've repented and that's a wonderful
thing and God rejoices over every lost
sheep that he finds
and that's wonderful
however unfortunately now Satan has a
lot of raw material to work with he's
got the perfect raw material because he
has your past sins on one hand which he
knows about and he's seen
and he delighted in when they were
happening and he takes it very
personally that you stopped doing those
things
so he has that on one hand the other
hand he has your love of God on the
other he also has your love of God
that's also raw material that he can
work with he can exploit both of them
can kind of play them off of each other
but you love God you've got your past
sins
so that's the material that he's working
now how do you know if your guilt has
this origin
is it you know does this guilt have
diabolical origin or does it have
heavenly fortune well if it's a repented
sin
and the guilt that you feel from it
leads to self hatred and despair
well then that's from Satan because God
would never give you those kinds of
feelings he doesn't want you to feel
that way
God will stir in your heart a guilt that
will drive you to repent
duration into Reformation he's going to
give you a gilt in other words that
brings you closer to him
but if your guilt is drawing you away
into the abyss into despair into
faithlessness into self-hatred into
resentment then you should know that
it's not God leading you there
buek satan in that case and give
yourself over to God and his protection
because that's that same
but
you know I guess we have to ask
ourselves is all guilt
you know is all guilt for past sin for
repentance is that always necessarily
the work of Satan
I don't think so and this is where it
gets confusing it's very difficult it
sometimes can be hard to discern it's a
it's a scary thing to think about but in
the you know as fallen people in our
conscience sometimes it can be hard to
discern is this a voice of light
speaking to her voice of darkness it can
be hard to discern sometimes and Satan
comes disguised as an angel of light so
but I don't think that all guilt that
you might feel even for past sins even
for repentance is I don't think it's
necessarily the work of Satan and it
would be a mistake to to to assume that
it is
because it could be a sign number one
that your repentance was not true it was
not sincere it was not complete
you know when you've lived deeply in
saying if you can you've done terrible
things to truly repent can sometimes be
a process to really get yourself to a
pointer to allow God to get you through
His grace to it to a point of really
confronting that
and feeling true sorrow for it that can
it's not something that will just happen
overnight
I think we're mistaken if we assume that
repentance and forgiveness are simple
and painless acts and we're mistaken if
we assume that our journey out of the
darkness is going to be quick and
comfortable it's not going to be it's
going to be a process take some time and
so you may think that you've
sufficiently repented but you may not
have
especially again if it's if it's a life
of sin and you in a fleeting moment say
oh my gosh I'm sorry
that may not be true repentance that may
just be an emotional experience that you
had a fleeting emotional experience
I'd ask you do you think take a let's
just take a really horrible thing so
think about a rapist or a murderer
can someone like that expect to repent
sincerely
from then on feel no guilt no pain no
sadness no grief no sorrow over what
they've done
of course not because our sins still
have consequences they still leave marks
they still cause scars in ourselves and
on other people they still have a weight
to them even when we repent and this
idea of cheap repentance kind of like
the cheap grace that Bonhoeffer talks
about it's very damaging it's very
misleading
after all the worst sins that that we
can commit are the sins that cause
scandal and hurt to other people and so
even if we've repented of the damage
that we've done to other people
the other people may still have to live
with what we've done depending on what
it is they miss they may still have pain
for the rest of their lives they may
still have even even worse than that you
know if we have been Christians and
we've we've given a very bad example
we've scandalized other people with our
example and led them into sin it's a
terrible thing it's the worst thing
and those people may still be struggling
because of us
and if we've really repented and we
really love God and we really love our
fellow man of course we're going to
still feel some pain about that
a truly repented rapist is going to
realize that well the person that he
raped is still out there
and they still are going to suffer from
this for the rest of their lives
and I think this you know this becomes a
stumbling block for a lot of people who
maybe are considering becoming Christian
and they hear about this really cheap
idea of repentance and forgiveness and
it causes a life heard to some people it
causes them to to to think twice about
about becoming Christian because it just
doesn't there's something about it seems
almost sociopathic
and they'll say like are you telling me
that someone can do all these horrible
things other people and victimize them
and then just in a second say oh I'm
sorry and they're good to go and they
could just live the rest of their life
just whistling on by whistling through
the rose bushes and just you know like
smelling the roses not even thinking
about what they've done to anybody else
that's not right
well no that's not the way it is
course if we have done terrible things
then we've hurt other people especially
we're going to feel pain
it shouldn't be debilitating it
shouldn't be a self-loathing pain it
shouldn't lead us away from God and into
the spare
but it may still be there
and depending on what it is it may
always be there
and so maybe we have to live with it we
have to carry it
it's our cross
that we have made for ourselves and it's
our burden and we have to accept it in
humility and carry on
at the very least I think
if we still have a certain pain over the
thought of things we've done to other
people
that's a pain that God may give to us
and one of the things that he wants us
to do with it for sure is to pray for
those other people
if we have ever scandalized somebody or
victimized them in any way we should be
praying for them like every day we
should be praying for them for the rest
of our lives
that's what true repentance is it's not
it's just not good enough to say but
sorry I guess they'll have to deal with
that anyway I'm gonna go over here good
luck with all that that I did to you see
you later
ourselves for it but I mean
it's just it's it's it's not as simple
as that
there's just riding off into the sunset
like it never happened
one other thought I've found that I will
experiment one other thing about that
again this is and I think it's just so
important to draw this distinction
that even remembering past things we've
done you know the pain that comes with
that I know I already said this but I
just think it needs to be emphasized
that it is not a self-loathing pain and
if it gets into self-loathing territory
then that is not from God
it's not so it's it's more of
just throwing ourselves at the mercy of
God going to God
and saying you know I know I've done
this to everything I've repented of it
what else can I do though I want and
maybe I don't need to do anything but
what else can I I want to do more
to try to make it right to try to
correct what I've done and so one of
those things God might say is well you
know you've hurt somebody you've done
pray for them that's one thing
all right one of the thought I've I've
often found that I will experience
myself pangs of a serious guilt in
moments when I find myself condemning
other people in my heart
and so then I'll feel guilt not just for
the condemnation but also for a past sin
of my own you know a similar sin to the
one that I am noticing in another person
will often come to the forefront of my
mind when I am busy noticing someone
else's sin now who causes that to happen
that's not from say the last thing Satan
would do is that he prefers it if we if
we stew an ark in our condemnation and
resent of our fellow man he doesn't want
to interrupt that process at all
know that again is guilt in pain from
God he's trying to give you humility
he's not holding it against you he's not
trying to torment you but he's just
saying I know this when this happens to
me he's saying to me what he said to the
crowd that were going to stone the
adulterous woman he's just saying he who
is without sin
and he's also saying you know remember
your past remember your sin remember
because I want you to remember what I've
delivered you from because I'm merciful
you're no better than the person that
you condemned so have humility
don't don't use my mercy and my
forgiveness and my generosity as a means
or as a reason for you to become
prideful and arrogant
God wants to I don't think it's true
that God wants us to forget our past in
our sins does not want us to forget
because if we forget our sin and our
past then we forget about his mercy and
his love and we said we cannot
appreciate it
and be grateful for it
so I think he may bring that to the
forefront of our mind sometimes to
Humble us and also to give us gratitude
and joy
so that we can remember like oh my gosh
I think about that thing that I did but
yet he's forgiven
I do this with my own kids sometimes I
recently my son got in trouble for
yelling at his sister and then yelling
at me after I tried to correct him and
his sister was kind of triumphant about
it you know as kids can tend to be in
these situations
and so his sister came up to me and she
said Oh daddy Oh Luc was really wrong
for yelling like that I'm so glad that I
didn't yell
and of course I had to say to her you
know yeah he was he made a mistake he
shouldn't have acted that way you have
also acted that way in the past
so let's remember that everybody makes
mistakes including you
my way of trying to teach her a little
bit of humility and also compassion for
her brother
so that she's not taking delight in the
fact that he got punched
think that God who is our Heavenly
Father can kind of do the same thing
with us because we're his children and I
think a lot of times we need that
reminder
a little bit of pain a little bit of
guilt attached to it when we feel it but
but that's good
so I hope I hope I hope some of that was
it was useful those are my thoughts
about about guilt
and but if you're really struggling with
it remember that you can never pray too
much
and probably almost all of us are
praying too little I know I am
so always just bring it back to God
and ask him what do you want me to do
with this what are you trying to teach
me what are you trying to show me
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed